los demócratas de Suecia antes una
aparida de la política sueca ahora se
quedan con un 20% de los votos A qué se
debe este auge tiene toda la razón es un
grupo particular es un partido político
Que obviamente digamos arranca con una
tradición un poco oscura digamos es una
tradición Claro que sí que ha tratado de
purificar su imagen desde su ingreso al
legislativo pero que de manera muy
inteligente ha aprovechado el contexto
sobre todo el aumento por ejemplo en la
criminalidad de dentro de Suecia el
nivel de asesinatos ha aumentado de
alguna forma han asociado ese tipo de
problemas internos con algunos de sus
grandes banderas de campaña Como por
ejemplo el control a la inmigración o la
reducción de la inmigración Y de esa
forma obviamente han obtenido un apoyo
popular digamos que buscas la
transformación y Busca un cambio en esta
situación y Busca un cambio de alguna
forma en la política de puertas abiertas
que se había implementado con el
gobierno anterior
hablemos un poco de los orígenes de ese
movimiento supone un avance una amenaza
para los derechos de las minorías en
Suecia
es un riesgo pero de nuevo tal como yo
lo mencioné efectivamente Aunque nació
de un movimiento muy oscuro
efectivamente con su participación
dentro del legislativo ha tratado de
excluir a los elementos más radicales de
la población digamos de su movimiento
para asumir y finalmente ganar una mayor
aprobación dentro de la estructura
política sueca ahora su posición sin
embargo es bastante fuerte sobre todo
con los inmigrantes Y eso significa que
aquellos que de alguna forma han
encontrado asilo en Suecia y que no se
han podido integrar tal como tal como se
discutido eventualmente tiene la tienen
el riesgo de estar excluido por supuesto
dentro de dentro de esta nueva propuesta
política y por otro lado está claro que
las puertas para los nuevos inmigrantes
estarán muy reducidas y finalmente las
posibilidades de emigrar a Suecia
buscando incluso asilo estarán muy
limitadas por factores culturales
factores religiosos incluso factores
étnicos
sin embargo su líder Jimmy Anderson no
tiene posibilidades de convertirse en
Primer Ministro al no contar con el
apoyo de los otros partidos de derecha
cree que se quedarán por fuera del
gobierno
Es una posibilidad efectivamente su
posición de alguna forma es demasiado
radical para los otros tres partidos que
hacen parte de la coalición Por lo cual
efectivamente los moderados son los que
toman el liderazgo y existen Entonces el
riesgo de que efectivamente digamos allá
haya una no participación de los de los
de los demócratas suecos en esta
colisión sin embargo esto dependerá
mucho de la forma como si empiece a
desarrollar o implementar el nuevo
gobierno y el tipo de propuestas que
pueda ofrecer Y de alguna forma que tan
alineadas estarán con estas visiones más
radicales de este partido